- [male voice] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit
our website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- We are the paradoxical ape, bi-pedal,
naked, large brain, long the master of
fire, tools and language, but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable yet filled with optimism. We
grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge. We
empathize and deceive. We shake the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are and how we got here. An exploration
made possible by the generosity of humans
like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Mark] Before I start you'll notice that
there are actually two speakers here. I'm
going to speak out of both sides of my
mouth. The other speaker listed here is
Carol Padden who was summoned to
Sacramento in her deaconal duties.
And so, Carol asked me to
present the work.
Carol and I have
known each other since she was a toddler
and we've been doing this. This particular
work is joint work of a large number of
people spread around the world and I
happen to be the other member of this
group present here and so I've been given
this honor. Here are some of the other
places. There's UCSD here of course, Tufts
University in Boston, and University of
Haifa in Israel. If you look very
carefully, you can see me. Let me see. In
any case, you could see a head behind the
van. My job for the last 15 years has been
to drive the van because that's a man's
job and that's what I do. Okay. I've
talked very briefly about sign languages
of the world. First really most important
thing is that there is no single universal
sign language. There are many sign
languages and we've actually learned a
little bit about Nicaraguan sign language.
Sign languages in general are young
languages.
They're usually small languages. There are
some very large ones like American sign
language but American sign language or
Japanese sign language, those are actually
atypical in terms of their size. What are
these languages used for? Well, they're
used for social communication like any
other language. Most sign languages are
actually quite young. The ones we're going
to be talking about are very new and were
actually created spontaneously in much the
same way as Nicaraguan sign language.
Others, the oldest sign language for which
we have actual records is French sign
language from which American sign language
comes. But we actually have records from
classical Greek times indicating that
people were signing back then and there is
a wonderful picture that I don't have here
of a Greek vase that seems to indicate
people signing thousands of years ago.
Most sign languages are fairly small
languages and those are the ones that
we're going to be kind of concentrating on
here. We're also interested in new sign
languages, sign languages that are
emerging, and this is very much within the
spirit of what we're talking about here.
You can actually watch languages evolve.
If you can't watch language as a human
ability evolve but individual languages
you can actually watch. Now, these new
sign languages they're created under a
variety of conditions, villages, schools,
wherever deaf people can find each other
they will pretty much create a sign
language. And the patterns that how these
sign languages are transmitted, vary quite
widely among each other. But what really
matters is that sign languages usually
start off as being iconic.
So we're very much within some of the
stuff that Kenny showed you, where you
start off with some sort of iconic
patterns. Eventually they become less
iconic and this is something I could show
you examples of later. It's really quite
wonderful. But they are all built on the
resources of the body, so people have a
body and they use this physical body in
order to communicate visually with one
another. All right. Sign languages of the
world, there are many and there are many
different types. Home sign, this is the
language of the individual who grows up in
a household where everyone else is
hearing. There are family sign languages
a case that's just emerged recently. It's
something that it's called natural sign
language. It's just a sign language that
is grown up in Nepal, among a community of
people. It's called natural because it
grew up by itself, not under any kind of
forced circumstances. Village sign
languages, that's a very recent, I'd
say the last 20 years or so people have
begun interested in that and that our
work basically is we work with village
sign languages. And then, of course, the
Nicaraguan sign language which grew up in
a near urban environment but which is also
very new. The point is there are these
many, many different kinds of sign
languages. So our question is, well, how
did they get that way? We know what
they're for and we know quite vividly as
we've seen examples already. These people
can communicate quite well but how did
they get there? And how did they get there
so quickly? Even the youngest sign
languages have grammatical categories.
They have fairly well defined word orders.
They have modifiers, these kind of
trappings of fully evolved sign languages.
So how did they get there? Well, the way
they get there is basically as we said by
using the body and originally by using the
body in iconic ways. Now I'm going to be
talking to you about a very, very small
type of organization but I think it is
emblematic of how sign languages can use
iconic patterns to organize themselves.
Okay. So we have to make a distinction
between two different types of iconicity.
I'll get to you in a second how that
works. So, what we're going to do is we're
kind of combining I think two of the
source of presentations that you've seen
here. We're going to be looking at
gesturers, non-signing hearing gestures,
and we're going to compare what their
gestures look like with the signs of
signers of new sign languages. In this
particular test, we're going to
concentrate on a fairly narrow task in
which we ask people, both hearing
gesturers and signers, to identify objects
in a picture task. So we show them a
picture and then we just ask them to
describe that picture. For the hearing
people we just say, "Please gesture." Do
not speak. And for the signers we just ask
them to sign the thing for us. Okay, so
that's the test. We showed them pictures
of tools and you'll see why it's
important.
We vary the number of tools so they don't
worry about whether the task, we kind of
are distracting them in a way. So they
think we care about how many but we don't
really care about how many. We just care
about what it is. All right. Now, very
important point. We're going to
distinguish two types of iconicity. The
first we're calling here imagistic
iconicity and that is simply to depict
something. But what we're really
interested in is patterned iconicity and
this is again within the spirit of what
you've seen so far today. The point is
that when languages emerge, patterns
emerge, right? So we're interested in the
emergence of patterns. We'll see here that
this is a very surprising pattern that's
going to emerge here and it's very small.
It's not a big pattern, just a small
pattern. But I hope you'll see that it's a
pretty cool pattern. Okay, all right. So,
what we're going to show you is we show a
picture of three paintbrushes and we asked
UCSD undergraduates to depict those in
gesture.
Now you could see what they're depicting
is how the hand holds the object, that's
what they're doing, right? So these are
handling. They're not very well dressed
but we'll have to ignore that.
Your basic UCSD undergraduates.
This guy is quite animated. All right. So
everybody sees what they do. Now what
we're going to do is we're going to show
you the same task except these are young
signers of Al-Sayyid Bedouin sign language
which we have talked about at previous
CARTA meetings. This is a brand new sign
language that was created in an
isolated Bedouin village by a population
initially of four siblings. This is a
village with a very high rate of recessive
deafness. Okay. And you're going to see a
big difference. What you're going to see
is that these people just don't depict how
you handle the object but they actually
show what the shape of this tool is,
right? All of them. And by the way, we
haven't selected this. This is what they
do. People of different ages. Oh, let me
ask a question. Did anybody notice
the word order difference between the two
populations? Right. So the UCSD
undergraduates do the number first and
then the thing and the Bedouin signers do
the thing first and then the numbers. So
they actually have a different word order
which I think is very cool. That's the
sort of thing linguists think is cool,
right? Okay. So we have these two terms.
We have this term handling to talk about
what people are doing and then we have
this term instrument to talk about showing
the actual thing. So what we're going to
show you is there's actually a difference
between the two groups.
Basically, the gesturers concentrate on
simply the handling, how you use it
whereas the signers will depict this as an
instrumentin other words they show you how
you use it but they're most interested how
to depict what the thing is. Okay. All
right. And we're looking at this in terms
of a pattern of iconicity that these
things share. Okay. All right. And you can
see this, actually not just across
communities but even within a
community. So what we have here is a
hearing Bedouin gesturer and he will tend
to use the handling whereas the deaf
member of the same community will also
depict the object as an instrument.
Handling versus instrument. Okay. Now,
question is do we get differences across
groups? And that is of course what
happens. So here are hearing Americans.
They are overwhelmingly handling, hearing
Bedouins show almost the same
distribution. Here is the Bedouin signers,
right? The opposite. And guess what, we
get the almost the same pattern for
American sign language. So hearing
gesturers concentrate on handling whereas
the deaf signers concentrate on the
instruments. And again we've given you the
same graph but in a slightly different
format to see how this works.
Okay. Now I'm going to show you another
experiment that actually I think gives you
maybe a slightly more subtle insight into
how all of this works. So what we do in
this experiment is we compare responses to
pictures with responses to video clips. By
the way, just a small autobiographical
point here, we used to use pictures all
the time when we first went into the
Bedouin village. We would just show people
pictures and the older Bedouin signers
really had no idea what to do. And we
thought that, "Well, it's just a picture.
Doesn't everybody know how to name a
picture? I mean, after all, you do that at
first grade." And then it suddenly
emerged. "Duh, first grade. These people
never got to first grade." It turns out
that picture naming is a learned kind of
task. There's nothing natural about naming
pictures. People living out there in the
wild don't have pictures that they could
point at. So this was really a lesson
a cross-cultural lesson to us. We were
interested in whether simply showing
people a static picture versus showing
people a video would have an effect. And
of course it did, otherwise we wouldn't
bother to show it to you, right? Okay. So
this is what we showed people. So here is
simply a brush and here is a video clip of
somebody using the brush. Everybody sees
that? Okay. And we compare people's
responses to those and it is of course
actually what you might expect. So when
you show people a video, even gesturers,
they're much more likely to use handling.
But when you show gesturers a picture then
they are much more likely to use
instruments. Now a little bit of tortured
reasoning here, but the fact that they
were responding so overwhelmingly to the
handling response, the gesturers were
responding so overwhelmingly to the
handling response even with the pictures
shows you that there is this major
difference between how the gesturers are
organizing their signal and how the
signers are organizing their symbol. So
what we see is that there is this
difference, right? That it's been somehow
conventionalized and amplified in this one
sign language which is the Bedouin sign
language and even more so in the sign
language, in American sign language. I'm
not going to talk about it here, but it
turns out that when you look at other sign
languages, we looked at Israeli sign
language, it doesn't work that way. So I
think what's going on is that signers pick
up, they pick up on these patterns this is
what we've seen before in earlier
presentations. They're picking up on these
patterns and what matters more is the
consistency of the abstract underlying
pattern. This is a very abstract notion of
handling versus also depicting the
instrument that they are picking up on.
And by the way, when you show people
pieces of fruit, this doesn't happen
because of course pieces of fruit they're
not instruments, at least not usually.
Okay. All right. I think what's the one
takeaway lesson that is really important
is that people have a drive to
communicate. We've talked about this. They
have a drive to share which Tecumseh Fitch
coined this wonderful German word which is
mitteilungsbedürfnis which only in German,
right? But it basically means the need to
share. And what we're seeing in all of
these cases is that you can increase the
power of your sharing by organizing your
system and that's what is going on here.
So, thank you, and Carol thanks you as
well.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪
- [David] The basic problem I address here
is one of how did languages come to do
what they do in terms of taking small
meaningless units and combining them to
make meaningful words. So using some
English examples, sat, sit, sad. Each time
I change one of the sounds we get a
different word. Sat, bat, fat, same thing.
So what I'm going to argue for is that
this is a commentatorial system and by
looking at sign language evidence, we can
see what things are like in some ways
before such a system evolves and get some
clues about how such a system evolves. I'm
going to be using primarily data from
American Sign Language and a lot of people
when they see signs they say, "Oh, it's
all iconic." And
a lot of the signs look iconic i.e. that
you could guess the meaning from seeing
the sign. So for example, drink, bird,
house, all of those you can get a pretty
good idea of the meaning from the sign
itself. However, those look like, they
look like gestures. You're gesturing
something about the meaning. But really in
a mature sign language like American Sign
Language, it has the same type of
combinatoriality within the word that I
illustrated with those examples from
English. And the signs consists of smaller
parts combined in different ways to
produce different signs with different
meanings. To find out what these smaller
parts are, we have to find examples of
signs that differ in only one respect. And
I'm going to show you some examples now
where we can identify the smaller parts of
the signs by comparing signs that differ
in only one respect. And at the same time
be illustrating a second point that in
most you cases you cannot guess the
meaning from seeing the sign if you don't
already know the language. So first, I'll
show some signs that differ only in
handshake versus, versus. And unless you
know the language you probably don't know
that this means change, this means
translate, and this means interpret.
Similarly, bird which I showed you, print
or publish, 20. These show that the place
of articulation, there'll be a lot of that
later, makes a difference. So bird
articulated the edge of the lip, print or
publish on the other hand. And signs can
differ only in movement, name, short,
knife, egg. All of those I don't think you
would guess the meaning from seeing them
the first time and illustrate how signs
can differ in movement. And we'll
concentrate on these three things. So each
sign consists of a hand shape, a place of
articulation, and a movement. There's also
sometimes orientation plays a role. I will
set those cases aside since they won't be
essential to the points that are made
here. Each sign language has an inventory
of hand shapes, places of articulation,
and movements, and it's a combinatorial
phonological system that puts them
together yielding different signs with
different meanings. Some signs are fully
iconic. So bird, all of its smaller parts
which I'll call formatives, all of its
formatives contribute to the iconicity.
The hand shape is L, the movement the
index touches the thumb twice, place of
articulation, P.O.A. is at the edge of
the lip.
And all three of those contribute to the
iconicity and bird shares hand shape and
movement as I showed you before with
print/publish, or 20. And the place of
articulation is the same as in drink or in
famous also at the edge of the lips. So
bird is fully iconic, all of these
contribute to the iconicity. Some signs
are partially iconic and then an example
of that is heart one. I'll be talking all
together about two signs, heart. This is
an older form, later we'll see a newer
form. So that is this heart, very iconic.
The movement, a heart shape. Place of
articulation, left side of chest, about
where the heart is located. But there is
an arbitrary element, the hand shape is
this open eight hand shape which has
nothing to do with heart. It's completely
arbitrary. Some signers interpret the
heart shape the way I've been doing it
more or less the heart shape you see on
Valentines, for some it's an oval, for
some it's a circle. An important
distinction throughout this talk is the
distinction between gestures and signs.
And so I've coined a notation here to keep
them different. On the left is a gesture.
Trace a heart shape over region of the
heart which could be done with any finger
or fingers or combination as opposed to
the sign. So the gesture is in these
double angled brackets, a sign has these
three formatives and each of those is
enclosed in square brackets.
The very important here is the gestural
hypothesis that iconic signs evolved from
holistic gestures. So that the sign heart
on the right evolved from the gesture on
the left. And a piece of evidence for
that, if that is the case that the sign
heart one evolved from the gesture heart,
this hypothesis makes a prediction that
early on there would have been variation
in the finger or fingers used to trace the
heart shape since that hand shape plays no
role in the gesture itself which is just
trace the heart shape. It doesn't say
anything about which finger or fingers.
And in fact there is evidence that that is
correct, that there was variation early
on. I'm indebted to Brandon Scates for
bringing to my attention that an 1884
book, "Deaf mutes describe a small surface
over heart and pointing downwards."
Saying nothing about which finger or
fingers. And Higgins, 1923, "Right index
points to heart or right thumb and index
trace shape of heart in region of heart or
both index tips trace shape of heart."
And notice that none of these are the open
eight hand shape used for heart in ASL. So
this is one kind of evidence for the
gestural origin of the sign heart. Now,
what distinguishes one sign from another?
And I'm going to show you two signs now
that differ only in place of articulation.
And this one means Canada, this one means
Yom Kippur. And the only difference is
whether I do it at the place of
articulation on my right side here of the
chest or the left side. Okay. Now, for
those of you who do not know ASL, I'm
going to do a sign and you tell me which
it means. Canada or Yom Kippur? How many
say Canada? How many say Yom Kippur? Okay.
It looks about evenly split to the extent
I can see. Well, actually this means
Canada but before I said this means Canada
and this means Yom Kippur, why doesn't
this mean Yom Kippur? I'm doing it with my
left hand before I did it with my right
hand. What this shows is that the relevant
distinction is not between right and left
on the chest. And I'll introduce the terms
ipsilateral. This is Latin, ipsi is same,
lateral is side. An ipsilateral sign or
sign's place of articulation is on the
same side as the articulating hand.
Contralateral signs are articulated on the
opposite side. So Canada, ipsilateral and
I'm right-handed. This is Canada, this is
Yom Kippur. A left-handed person this is
Canada, this is Yom Kippur.
The crucial thing is whether it's
ipsilateral or contralateral. Now let's go
back to heart and I'm going to show you
the other sign for heart which I'm
right-handed, so this is heart. And that
seems like the place of articulation is
iconically motivated. But how would have a
left hander sign heart? Why? Because it's
contralateral. I'm right-handed I sign it
over here where the heart is located more
or less. But for a left hander, it's also
contralateral so we sign over here. So
this is an important fact and this
illustrates the major transformation that
has taken place in what I'm talking about
today. Namely that the formal
characterization of place of articulation
as either ipsilateral or contralateral
trumps the iconicity. These things started
out iconic with the movement being iconic,
the place of articulation where the heart
is located. But once they evolve from
gestures to signs, we now have a system
where the formal properties of the signs
take over and trump the original iconic
motivation of the form coming from the
original iconic gesture.
This gives us a way of seeing formal
properties of signs as opposed to the
gestures from which they derive. And right
and left have no place but ipsilateral,
contralateral are essential. So let me
show you some other signs now where you
can see the same thing. So direction of
movement is either ipsilateral or
contralateral. So I'll show you the signs
for right and left. When I sign right, my
hand moves to the right. When I sign left,
my hand moves to the left. But really,
when I sign right, my hand is moving in
the ipsilateral direction and when I sign
left my hand is moving in the
contralateral direction. So, when a
left-handed person signs right, the hand
moves in the ipsilateral direction which
is to the left. And when a left-handed
person signs left, the hand moves in the
contralateral direction which is to the
right. This shows very clearly that
what's relevant is the formal properties
of the place of articulation, not the
original iconic motivation which you see
in the right-handed signing but the
left-handed signing turns that on its
head. Also, I want to dispel any idea you
might have gotten that the gestural source
of particular signs might only have been
in the distant past and also that there's
any physical difference necessarily
between gestures and signs. So the sign
Yom Kippur that I've been illustrating has
a gestural source which is this which is
physically exactly the same as the sign.
It's done in the synagogue service on Yom
Kippur. There's a prayer, it's a communal
confession of various kinds of sins. Each
type of sin as it's mentioned, the
worshipers go like this.
What do the left handers do?
This is the gesture that is the source of
the sign Yom Kippur, physically identical
to it. For left handers in the synagogue
service, it goes to the place where the
heart is located which is here on the left
side. But when they sign the sign Yom
Kippur which is evolved from that gesture,
it's on the opposite side, the
contralateral side because Yom Kippur is a
contralateral sign. Okay. So this
difference between gestures and signs is
the key thing. The signs have certain
formal properties. They evolved from
gestures but once they have these formal
properties they can turn out quite
differently. And we can generalize, some
of the other papers have talked about
this, Mark Aronoff and Carol Padden just
before this. A more general gestural
hypothesis that sign languages have their
earliest stages in gestural communication
and have evolved from that to current sign
languages. And a very great
confirmation of this is the Al-Sayyid
Bedouin sign language that Mark Aronoff
just mentioned in his presentation where
he and three others have been studying
this new Bedouin sign language in Southern
Israel which does not have a combinatorial
system, a combinatorial phonological
system putting parts together as we saw
here.
Okay, one last point. Comparative
cross-species evidence from language
experiments with chimpanzees. These are
chimpanzees that people signed with
for years and years. Rivas did 22 hours of
video tape and eliminated all cases where
they just repeated what the human had
signed within the previous five seconds.
Here's the number of different signs each
of these chimps produced and their four
most frequent signs accounted for 58%,
45%, etc. of their total output. The main
thing is after years of this, why is their
vocabulary so small? The explanation: that
chimps learn no signs at all, only a small
set of holistic gestures. And a deeper
explanation for that is that they don't
have the combinatorial abilities that
humans have to have a combinatorial system
putting meaningful words or signs together
from smaller units. This suggests strongly
that these combinatorial abilities of
humans developed after the split between
the human and chimpanzee lineages.
Thank you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪
- [Ray] I should first give equal billing
to Eva Wittenberg who did a lot of this
work with me. Can you identify yourself
there? Yeah, right there. One of the big
questions for anthropogeny is how did
language evolve in our species. And even
this is a big question my almost five year
old granddaughter asked a couple of weeks
ago. She asked, "How did people make up
words when there weren't words before?" So
I mean it's an obvious question. Well,
here's the thing. Languages are learned by
children and their progress looks like
learning other things like motor skills
and social skills. So a lot of people
think there's nothing more to it than
that. Humans just got to be good at
learning stuff. So I want to restate the
question not how did human language evolve
but how did humans evolve so as to be able
to learn language as well as those other
things? And in order to answer this you
have to ask another question, when you
learn a language, what do you end up
knowing? For starters, learning a language
is being able to map between patterns of
sounds or gestures on one hand, and
meanings or thoughts or concepts, whatever
they are. So something like this. So when
you're speaking you're going upwards in
this picture from meanings to producing
sounds, and when you're understanding
you're going downward. Now let me add a
little bit of the big picture, conceptual
structures are also linked to perception
and action. So you can talk about what you
see and you can talk about what actions
you plan to carry out and so on. Now, just
for fun, what do you get if you take away
phonetic patterns like this? Well, you get
an organism that can perceive and have
thoughts and act based on those thoughts.
And I think this is a plausable sketch of
ape cognition which is pretty
sophisticated, but it doesn't have
language. So the evolution of language had
to involve at least a new ability to map
concepts to sounds and gestures and to use
these communicatively. Well, we've been
hearing this all day. Well, linguists
actually think there's a good deal more to
that than language. First comes
phonological structure which is the
systematized organization of sounds or
gestures and we just heard about that from
David Perlmutter in ASL. Second one is
morphology, the internal structure of
words such that a word like, say
procedurally can be seen as built form
proceed plus ure to form procedure plus al
to form procedural plus ly to perform
procedurally. And the third one is syntax,
the organization of words into phrases
and sentences. So syntax determines things
like canonical word order. So if you hear
something like the boy kissed the girl you
know who did the kissing and who got
kissed. It also allows you to elaborate
descriptions of characters and events into
phrases. So something like the boy in the
blue hat and red sneakers tried to kiss
the girl that he loved. And you still know
that the boy did the kissing even though
the word boy is nowhere near kiss, and
you also know that he loved the girl
even though the boy is nowhere near love.
So language in modern humans involves this
part circled in red of the network of
cognitive organization. And what's evolved
in humans is the ability to learn to do
this kind of thing, to turn thoughts into
sounds by structuring them into words and
phrases and to be able to pull thoughts
out of the sounds that other people make.
Well, how could this have happened?
Basically there's no direct evidence for
what our ancestors talked about and when
they started talking. There aren't any
fossil vowels.
The usual way to test evolutionary
scenarios is comparison to other species.
But here it isn't too helpful as we've
heard already today, modern apes don't
learn very much in the way of human
languages and they certainly don't invent
language spontaneously as deaf children do
in the absence of sign language input as
we also have heard about today. So there's
a big cognitive gap between apes and
humans here. Another way to form plausible
hypothesis about evolution is through
reverse engineering, figuring out what
components could have been useful in the
absence of others. So think about the eye,
a primitive retina would have been useful
for vision. Without the muscles that move
the eyeballs although it might be more
limited than our modern vision. On the
other hand, without a retina, the muscles
wouldn't help you see at all. So it makes
sense that something like the retina
probably evolved before the muscles. I
want to propose something like that for
language. So a primitive system for
communicating thoughts via sounds and
gestures is useful without phonology,
morphology, or syntax. These components
can improve an existing communication
system but they're useless on their own.
So if the components of language evolved
in some order it makes sense that the
connection between phonetics and meaning
came first and then these further
refinements going from there. So the
hypothesis is that this is the kind of
system that some ancestors of
modern humans could learn. I can't prove
that this is the way language evolved but
what I'll try to do today is to show you
the simpler systems of the sort exist in
the languages of today and show you how
these systems, a little bit, about how
these systems work. And the basic idea
comes from Derek Bickerton. He proposed
that there's a form of language that he
called Protolanguage which surfaces in
many different circumstances and he
proposed that this form of language is a
relic of early stages in the human or
hominid system.
I'm going to suggest that this form of
language is a subset of the full language
system. It emits morphology and syntax and
I'll call it a linear grammar. What is a
linear grammar like? Well, it has words
and the words have to come in some order.
They map to meanings but there's no
structure. There aren't syntactic phrases
like the boy in the blue hat and red
sneakers or structure inside words as we
saw with the word procedurally. Now in
this kind of language, word order could
still matter. You could say boy kiss girl
and mean the boy did the kissing and the
girl got kissed, not vice versa. But it
wouldn't be because the subject proceeds
the verb and the verb proceeds the object,
because a linear grammar can't have
syntactic things like nouns and verbs and
subjects and objects. What it still has
is semantic notions like the word denoting
an actor, here the boy, proceeds the word
denoting the action namely kiss. That is
this kind of language would map directly
between linear order and phonology and the
meaning. Now linear grammar doesn't have
morphology so the kind of things like
tenses and agreement on verbs, so you'll
get boy kiss girl, not boy kissed girl or
boy kisses girl. You'll leave it up to the
context to indicate when this kissing took
place. And you might also expect not to
have functional items like definite
articles which perform a syntactic role
namely marking noun phrases than a
semantic one. And a linear grammar is
linear so it can't have subordinate
clauses like the relative clause and the
girl that he loved. You might still
express this thought but maybe as two
sentences. You might say something like
boy love girl, kiss girl. Something like
that. Well, I want to tell you about some
systems that look like this. The first one
is pidgins. These are the early stages of
contact languages as we also heard about
earlier today.
This is great, this symposium just set up
my talk perfectly. Pidgins are often
described as having no subordination, no
morphology, no grammatical words like the,
and they have unstable word order that's
governed by semantic principles like actor
before action. If the context permits you
can leave out characters and the action.
So if you already knew about the girl you
might just say boy kiss, where English
would make you use a pronoun like the boy
kissed her. So from the perspective of
linear grammar we can ask, "Is there any
evidence that Pidgins have parts of speech
like nouns and verbs?" Is there any
evidence for syntactic phrases? And my
preliminary conclusion is there's very
little evidence for it and I suggest that
Pidgins would be a good example of a
linear grammar. Later on of course,
contact languages add many features of
more complex languages like
conventionalized word order, grammatical
category, syntactic subordination. Again
as we heard today and these kinds of
languages are called Creoles. And Eva and
I see the transition form from a Pidgin to
a Creole as going not from it's not a
language, it's just junk to a language.
Now it's a language, but just adding some
syntactic and morphological principles
that weren't there in the Pidgins, just
goosing it up a little bit. For a second
case, Wolfgang Klein and Clive Perdue did
a multilanguage longitudinal study of
immigrants all over Europe learning second
languages, and they found that all
speakers achieved a stage of what you
might call semi-proficiency that Klein and
Perdue call the Basic Variety. Many
speakers went on to improve on it but
others just stop there. That's as far as
they got. And in this stage as they
describe it, there's no inflectional
morphology, no tenses, no plurals and so
on. No sentential subordination. You can
leave out known characters freely.
There's simple and semantically based
principles of word order including our
favorite actor before action. That is from
our standpoint the basic variety also
looks like another kind of linear grammar.
Third case is home sign. As we've heard
already the languages invented by deaf
children who have no exposure to a sign
language. And Susan Goldin-Meadow has
shown that they have at most rudimentary
morphology. They freely omit known
characters and on our analysis, they only
have a semantic distinction of object
versus action, not a syntactic distinction
of noun versus verb. The word order is
kind of probabilistic but if anything it's
based on semantic roles. Home signers do
produce some sentences with multiple verbs
or action words if you don't think they
have verbs. Goldin-Meadow has in the past
described these as embedding. We think
these are rudimentary serial verb
constructions which I can't explain to non
linguists, I'm sorry. So it looks to us
like a linear grammar with possibly a bit
of morphology added and I should add to be
perfectly honest, Goldin-Meadow doesn't
agree with us altogether, so this is
controversial. Another case we've looked
at is village sign languages which develop
in isolated communities where there's a
significant occurrence of hereditary
deafness. And the best known of these is
ABSL which we've just heard about from
Mark Aronoff. I'm going to talk about
Central Taurus Sign Language or CTSL which
is spoken in a couple of remote villages
in the mountains of Turkey. This language
came to my attention two years ago through
my student Rabia Ergin who remarkably has
deaf family members who live in the
village and speak it. You want to raise
your hand Rabia, our newest celebrity,
there she is. Rabia along with Naomi
Kaselli, Irit Meir and some of the people
from Carol Padden's group from about which
we've heard already have been documenting
this language and what they find is that
the language has a fair amount of
morphology but there's very little
evidence for syntactic structure.
In sentences involving one character so
somebody jumped or somebody fell down or
something, the word order is normally the
actor preceding the action. If there are
two character sentences with inanimate
patients like the boy rolled the ball,
it's normally, well, maybe you put in the
actor, maybe you don't, and then you put
in the thing that's acted upon and then
the action. But if there are two animate
characters, so the semantics alone can't
resolve the potential ambiguity. Word
order isn't very stable. It's a bit vague
whether the boy kissed the girl or vice
versa and there's a lot of reliance.
People rely a lot on
pragmatics and context.
In fact, there's a very strong
tendency to mention
only one of the characters in an event no
matter how many there are. So CTSL looks
like a linear grammar augmented by a
substantial amount of morphology and this
isn't too far off what we've seen in ABSL
and the earlier stages of Nicaraguan Sign
Language as we heard from Anny Sanges.
Now what's cool I think is that these less
complex systems aren't confined to
emerging languages. Townsend and Bever
discussed what they call semantically
based interpretive strategies that
influence language comprehension. Hearers
tend to rely in part on semantically based
principles of word order like actor
precedes action which is why on our story
they have more difficulty with
constructions such as reversible passives
and object relatives again for the
non-linguist it doesn't matter. Where the
actor doesn't precede the action, that's
the crucial thing. Similarly, Fernanda
Ferrera and her colleagues discussed what
they call good enough parsing where people
apparently rely on linear order and
semantic plausibility rather than
syntactic structure. And it's well known
that we see similar symptoms in language
comprehension by agrammatic aphasics.
And Heather van der Lely has argued that a
particular population of children with
specific language impairment behave as
though they're processing language through
something like a linear grammar. The
literature describes these so-called
strategies or heuristics has something
separate from language. But they're still
mappings between phonology and meaning.
They're just simpler ones that bypass
syntax. So we can conjecture that the
language processor makes use of both
syntactic grammar and the simpler linear
grammar and when the two kinds of rules
produce conflicting analyses, the
interpretation is slower and less stable
even when the syntax wins out. And when
the syntactic rules break down under
conditions of stress or disability then
the linear grammar is still there doing
its thing. We've also come across two full
blown languages whose grammar appears to
be close to a linear grammar and others
have come along that I haven't
looked at very closely yet. But one of
them is Riau Indonesian. This is a
vernacular with several million speakers
described by David Gil. Gil argues that
this language has no syntactic parts of
speech, no inflection or morphology like
tense or plural or agreement, known
characters in the discourse are freely
omitted, and things that English expresses
with syntactic subordination are expressed
in Riau by simply jamming simple sentences
together, like boy kiss love girl. The
word order is pretty free, but actors tend
to precede actions and actions tend to
precede patients. But here's some
illustration of the freedom of this
language. If you have the expression
chicken eat, this can mean all of these
different things depending on the context.
And the ones at the bottom where you say
chicken eat and you mean someone is eating
with the chicken, they require where
the chicken is eating, they require a lot
of contextual support but people do say
these things.
So this again looks like a linear grammar
so here's basically a full language that's
syntactically simple in our sense. Another
example is the controversial case of
Piraha, studied extensively by Dan
Everett. This has exuberant morphology, so
it's not simple in this respect. It seems
to have a syntactic noun-verb distinction
and fairly fixed word order but no
definite or indefinite articles, no
markers of plurality, no agreement, da,
da, da. Now Everett's most famous claim is
that Piraha lacks recursion that is
subordinate clauses. Everything that's
expressed in English with recursive syntax
either just jam simple sentences together
or require some sort of circumlocution. So
this looks like a syntactically relatively
simple language, though not as simple as
Riau Indonesian. So to sum up, we find
that's remarkably similar grammatical
systems turn up in all of these different
scenarios and this suggests that linear
grammar is quite a robust phenomenon
entrenched in the modern human brain. It
provides a scaffolding on top of which
fully syntactic languages can develop
either in an individual, as in the case of
the basic variety, or in a community as
we've seen with sign languages and
Creoles, and it provides a sort of
safety net when syntactic grammar is
damaged as we've seen with aphasia and
specific language impairment. And we've
also seen that you can say a lot without
syntax, for example in Riau Indonesian
though having syntax gives you a lot more
fancy tools for expressing yourself. So
let me go back to the original question
about the evolution of the human ability
to learn language. I suggest that we
can think about it through reverse
engineering asking what kind of system
there could have been that preceded the
modern human language faculty. And I think
linear grammar is a good candidate. As I
said at the beginning, I have no idea how
we could prove it nor when the hominid
line achieved either linear grammar or
syntactic grammar.
Maybe someday we'll get better evidence
from genetics but for now I'm happy to see
it as an intriguing hypothesis. So
altogether then, we think this is telling
us a lot of interesting and new things
about the texture of the human faculty and
I'm eager to get on with filling in the
picture further. Thank you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪